I agree with that I think Tom cotton is
saying this now a Republican and I think
Andrew yang you said this repeatedly and
I think everybody in the middle is
starting to say you know maybe you bi
universal basic income might not make
sense as an ongoing thing but boy does
it make sense now you know as one of the
people who's going to be stuck with the
the the problem with paying off the
national debt I don't see a better
reason to run up the debt maybe I've
never seen a better reason to run up the
debt than what we have right now so if
you say to me Scott Scott Scott the
deaths already an emergency we owe have
her many trillions we can't add two more
trillion to that to which I say compared
to what compared to watts I mean I'm one
of the people who's gonna have to pay
off that debt right because I have money
it's not poor people will pay off debts
it's people with money and I'm here to
tell you I'm okay with universal basic
income people gotta eat you've got to
keep the lights on right well the lights
will stay on but you know people were
temporarily without in a paycheck they
still need to go to the grocery store or
orders are on line groceries and I don't
think for me that shouldn't be even a
discussion because unless we have
another way to solve that specific
problem of getting those people who were
staying at home you know a paycheck if
somebody doesn't have a better answer
and I haven't heard one we should do
that today you know I don't know why
Congress hasn't already done that it
feels like a today problem not not next
week yeah it's really interesting you
bring this up was it yesterday or the
day before I got in an uber here in New
York City and when I got in the
gentlemen had on medical gloves the
driver and he had a n95 mask on and next
to him on the console he had a bunch of
hand sanitizer and wipes and we just
started talking and you know I basically
said you know how's it going is demand
going down you know do you think uber
will kind of shut down and lyft shut
down etc they said something really
interesting he goes a couple people have
gotten in and asked me why am i still
driving obviously given the fact that
I'm worried about the virus given all
the kind of personal protective
and he said and I keep reminding them I
saw bills to pay I start to feed my
family I saw I've rent to pay right no
one's going to kind of give me any help
and so I'm gonna keep driving until they
tell me to get off the road and I
thought it was you know just kind of the
purple of somebody who that that's what
he has to do right that's his living and
he's gonna keep doing it until either
they tell me to get off the road or or
he's gotta you know somehow get through
this you know kind of tough time yeah
people give me making a lot of tough
decisions one thing that might be a
little ray of hope is that the
restaurants are going to become delivery
kitchens basically and the existing
delivery people presumably are maxed out
because you know I used I used food
delivery four times yesterday
you know once once was a supermarket
order that we put in a week ago it just
took a week to get here and three times
I told by my crew here that they could
just use as much door - as I want as
long as they use the obviously it's
local restaurants it's just the support
the local restaurants so I basically
took the cap off for my family it's like
you're hungry I don't need to be with
you I don't need to you know you don't
need to ask me if you're hungry go
support a restaurant by going to your
computer and push the buttons you know
get a tip to the the delivery guy so I
think you can see over people becoming
food and product delivery people on top
of whatever little bit of human cargo
they have so that could help a little
for sure and then in terms of the ubi
I've got this friend Travis Klein who
always says that quantitative easing is
just you bi for rich people right and
kind of the idea that if we're gonna
quote-unquote bail people out or we're
going to inject kind of this liquidity
into the Wall Street finance world is
there really that big of a difference
between handing that would lead directly
to people and I think you get into
semantics between you know ubi purchases
mmm tea you know and people have
different versions of this
but at the end of the day it's the
concept of the government getting money
to individuals so that they can put that
money in their pocket and hopefully
stimulate that economic activity do you
mind if I curse your hat you're free to
do whatever you want
so you've been warned if you're if
you're listening the idea of doing any
kind of a trickle down approach in this
emergency is batshit [ __ ] crazy and
we should just cut it out like you know
unless there's some economist who was
gonna disagree with me I don't think so
you got people who need a check today so
they can buy some food you know whatever
whatever they need to buy I think you bi
we should be past the argument on that
and you know at least for the temporary
version that the permanent one
I think is added the question at the
moment but we can trial it see what
happens in the emergency maybe we learn
something also although it's unique
situation so probably we wouldn't learn
what we need to learn about a normal
situation but I I'm watching Congress
and I'm saying you know I'm very
forgiving about the issue of when did
you start you know because everything
could have been done sooner but I don't
think there's a pushback on this basic
idea that you can't wait for it to
trickle down and I'm real unhappy if
there's any politician saying something
like that be they Republican or be they
Democrat you're not qualified for your
job if you're talking about waiting for
its to trickle down and hope your hope
the business is kind to its employees
and stuff like that now just give them
the check give it to them right now
today is the day you know it's in the
emergency we're operating under what I
call TV time you know for people who
work on live TV if you've ever been in
this situation I've been in it a lot you
know waiting for the countdown and
you'll be chatting with the hosts and
there'll be seven seconds of little
airtime and the hosts will turn to be
and start a conversation and I'll be
sitting there you know the first times
that happen to me I'd like don't you
realize
there are only seven seconds you can't
start a conversation what are we going
to do in seven seconds and then you
realize that they they do the thing you
respond you go back and forth that the
light goes on and they look at the
camera and boom it's game time so
there's this this weird sense of
compressed time in the live TV world
that we need to take to Congress because
you know without exaggeration the ubi
thing should be done today and I don't
mean that hyperbolically I mean actually
Congress should get together and say
alright let's just do this thing because
we know we've got to do it sooner or
later let's just approve this thing
that's it today thing they should be on
TV time yeah and I don't remember all of
the details but I think it was in 2008
under George Bush um I came up with a
tax credit or an actual check but as
part of the financial crisis there's
like a $450 think wasn't exactly ubi but
but it's not like this has never
happened before
and to your point about this kind of
being a bipartisan thing at this point
so much a headlines yesterday that Mitt
Romney is even supporting you know kind
of $1,000 check for uh for individuals
and there's a lot of kind of you know
kind of excitement that Oh Mitt Romney
is saying this yeah we've got we've got
you know AOC you know Andrew yang Mitt
Romney I think Tom cotton is somewhere
in that neighborhood I'm there it's the
whole spectrum if you can't get that
done today when people in the entire
spectrum agree on it I got some
questions about Congress that's a today
thing I hate to harp on that but it's
not a tomorrow thing yeah and so that
brings me to let's get away from the
individuals and kind of the ubi now what
we're seeing is a lot of industries
going to the government and saying hey
we need assistance we need bailouts you
know kind of a whole spectrum of how
people are articulating what they're
asking for but essentially what they're
asking for our bailouts and whether it's
the airlines or other industries and I
think what's quickly becoming a somewhat
controversial debate is a lot of these
companies that are asking
or help or also companies have had very
high percentage of their free cash flow
devoted to stock buybacks so any ideas
kind of around how you evaluate the
bailouts of certain industries and kind
of how do we pick which ones get help
which ones don't and then also it does
the stock buybacks tough play and any of
this in your opinion or is that kind of
a separate issue and should enter the
disc well you're you're raising the
question of what's fair in a sense as
opposed to what is possible it's
probably possible to bail out these
industries you know given running up our
debt but we know we can do that
so it's possible what is it fair that's
really the question people are going to
ask and let me give you my emergency
crisis answer to the question of is it
fair don't care don't bother me with
that the last thing I'm going to even
engage with you is on a question of
fairness during an emergency and I had
that to have this conversation yesterday
with somebody and knock-knock Christina
but somebody in my life where I had to
explain that fairness is just nothing
that will you have any wait don't don't
tell me that argument don't tell me
what's fair don't want to hear it we're
in a position of you have to do what you
have to do so is it's a greater good
situation and if the greater good is
that we have a airline that goes back to
health we just got to do that all right
that's not a you know oh it's so unfair
the stockholders of the airline's
you know got got some free cash mmm
don't care you know I'm not even gonna
have that conversation with you the
conversation is Airlines yes or Airlines
no if it comes down to that it's gonna
be airlines yes and don't tell me
anything else just just be quiet
take your feelings about the fairness do
whatever you need to do to process them
but they're not part of the decision
that's ordinary ordinary world in an
ordinary world we'll talk about fairness
in emergency world it's not a thing yeah
and it's interesting that you kind of
position it that way of you know
fairness doesn't enter the equation
I think that's a pretty accurate way to
to evaluate it the other thing that I've
heard people argue is what I'll call
more kind of the free-market capitalism
which is hey if they've been bad
allocators of capital does that then
mean that we should encourage more
competition whether that is kind of on
in the extreme of let some companies
fail and they'll get replaced by new
challengers or actually should we divert
resources to help new challengers enter
the market how do you think about that
balance between you know maybe not
bailing out industries versus letting
them completely fail versus bail out and
then actually create a new paradigm or
new world for that industry moving
forward whether that's new regulatory
issues or competition yeah I think that
conflates the long term strategy with
the short term the short term is we
can't have no airline travel the long
term is how do you do it in the best
possible way and I think it's a mistake
to to mix those we're in an emergency
situation how do we get back to
something close to business as normal
that's that's the only thing I care
about if you're also trying to
complicate that by well you know let's
not let this crisis go to waste
maybe we could change some things and
change the industry and tweak it well
every time you add complexity you're
slowing things down you're adding a new
point of failure giving somebody else a
reason to say no to what they should be
saying yes to do so this is no time to
get clever and it's at least in that way
in terms of adding complications and
planning for something that well maybe
that would be better in some some way
it's just not the time for that but yes
maybe we learn something from this that
once were past the danger zone we can
apply it in the future but I don't want
to look back don't want to don't want to
focus about what the airline's did in
the past don't want to talk about
fairness well look at the future and the
greater good focus on that not the past
not fairness yeah you've got a very kind
of word emergency let's solve the
emergency I think
viewpoint which frankly is not not
commonly held by a majority of people so
it's kind of refreshing to hear that